most monolinguals speakers think that
other languages are basically just their
language with different words in a
slightly different order and maybe a
different way of writing turns out
though that there are lots of
interesting features in other languages
some of which English could really
benefit from having I'm going to talk
about four of them number one time
independence if you want to describe an
activity in English you have to say when
it happened or when it will happen you
have to
that's how verbs conjugate there is no
way in English to describe the concept
of a person and dancing but not to
mention anything about tongue Chinese on
the other hand verbs don't conjugate in
most cases the meaning is obvious from
context I don't want to imply that
Chinese doesn't have a tense system it
does it's just not a requirement it's
not banked into every single sentence by
default
side note tenses aren't as simple as
past present and future and there are
some lovely subtle tenses in other
languages more on that in a later video
anyway if you want to write poetry with
a more vague sense of time Chinese is
one of the languages to choose number
two blue civet II the word wheat is
confusing
imagine going up to someone and saying
hey we've just won the lottery there are
two possible meanings there number one
we refers to the speaker and the
listener we've just won the lottery
brilliant number two we refers to the
speaker and the speaker's friends but
not the listener we've just won the
lottery
but you haven't in languages with clue
civet e there are different words for we
depending on whether you're including
the listener or not it shows up in
languages in South Asia Australasia and
all over the world apart from Europe
I really wish English had clue civet e
because once you describe it it's a
blindingly obvious missing thing that we
we all could really use number three
absolute direction this isn't all that
useful but it is cool in a few languages
notably a couple of Australian ones like
Google you Murphy R that's the one
that's been extensively studied there
are no words for left right forward and
instead you always use cardinal
directions the equivalent words for
north south east and west
in this studio our North is that way so
right now I have a north foot
and a South foot if I turn I now have a
West foot and an East foot I think um I
mean I'm having trouble tracking
something simple like that but if you're
a native speaker of a language with
absolute direction your brain just
handles it
you always know which way you're
pointing and if you don't you have
trouble speaking as a language speaker
I'd say relative directions are a lot
more useful particularly for those of us
that go on the London Underground often
but it would be great to know always
which way was north and finally number
four evidential 'ti in the same way that
time is baked into english sentences
there are languages all over the world
where evidence is baked in if you're
reporting something that happened you
have to include whether you personally
witnessed it or not you can do this in
English of course I saw that I heard
that but it's not required some
languages have five or more different
categories of evidence based on whether
you saw it with your own eyes
experienced it firsthand but it didn't
involve seeing whether you've inferred
it from something else whether you're
reporting what some else has said all
these concepts which are fairly
complicated to explain in English are
expressed just by how you change the
ending of a word all these fantastic
features are one of the reasons why
keeping minor languages alive is
important if English had utterly
dominated the world and stamped out
every other tongue then we'd lose not
only these rich languages but we'd lose
the insights that we gained of what the
human mind is capable of so here's my
question to you can you think of a brand
new language feature something that
every language should have but doesn't
next time why things aren't always black
and white or blue or green